sir roger penrose worked with stephen
hawking became a knight and won the
nobel prize in 2020. nobel prize in
physics
with one half to roger penrose
for the discovery that black hole
formation is a robust prediction of the
general theory of relativity i bet you
think he's pretty much ineffable well
did you know that there's a way to prove
the great sir roger penrose wrong not
right stay tuned this episode will
explain a unique way that sir roger
penrose could be proven wrong not right
perhaps for the very first time join me
and go into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
concepts for how the universe began are
as old as time
many of us think that the big bang
theory is essentially correct with no
modifications needed of course those of
you who have tuned into my previous
videos will know that's not the case the
big bang even itself is quite
controversial we don't know for sure
that it occurred if it did occur how do
we know it occurred only once there are
many models that posit the universe
could have gone into and out of
existence in a way that i'll describe so
while sir roger is celebrating his 90th
birthday party just this past august and
i was pleased to present a talk in honor
of him happy three billion seconds and
to at least a billion more some of the
presents that i got him were slightly
ironic because we're hoping in some ways
to falsify his pet theory of how the
universe came to be not how it became to
originate because in his conception the
universe went through many many
iterations and cycles in what's known as
conformal cyclic cosmology today i want
to talk about alternatives to the single
big bang model and i'll explain in a way
that i hope will convince you that this
field is very rich we don't have any
reason just now to suspect that there
was only one big bang
of course the book of genesis and many
other cosmogenies origin of cosmology of
our universe posit a singular origin let
there be light in the beginning so it's
very important to realize there are
several different modern not ancient
i'll review the ancient ones in just a
bit but there are modern concepts of
just the past century that posit a
alternative to a single big bang here
are some of them of the quasi-steady
cosmology a bouncing universe of paul
steinhardt anna aegis neil turock and
others that we've talked about
previously the inflationary multiverse
which posits perhaps an infinite number
of universes coming into and out of
existence
conformal cyclic cosmology and the
so-called big crunch where you'd have a
universe that existed one time collapsed
and then produced the observational
signature that we see
in our observations of the universe now
all of these are at present consistent
with the origin of the universe as
consistent with data as could possibly
be and the question begins to
reflect on itself which is a better
solution
could there be a better interpretation
as we do have in quantum mechanics there
are interpretations in cosmology as well
shown here is my late great colleague
jeffrey burbidge who also had the same
office that i occupy at the university
of california san diego and he was of
course a titan of astronomy astrophysics
cosmology of the 20th century passing
away sadly in 2010 but he and sir fred
hoyle posited that the universe didn't
have a single origin in fact was slowly
evolving via a series of epicycles if
you will
known as the quasi-steady-state
cosmology this did not require a big
bang at all and even didn't require a
singularity which many people found
anathema to our understanding of physics
now we've talked about many times on
this channel the existence of
singularities should really be thought
of as a place where our equations break
down not a place of infinite temperature
infinite density uh other aspects of
physics that are unknown to our to our
contemporary existence
now i had an interview with giant
narlikar who is one of sir fred's
greatest colleagues and jeff and
margaret burbidge's colleague i remember
meeting him many times here at uc san
diego
i did an interview with him and his
lovely wife mangala uh earlier this year
in 2021 so look for this video uh on the
channel about now as recently as the
1970s
even after therefore the discovery of
the cosmic microwave background
in 1965 by penzias and wilson stephen
weinberg said the steady state theory is
philosophically the most attractive
theory because at least resembles the
account given in genesis in other words
it's as a biblical as possible
now conformal cyclic cosmology or ccc
also has a very distinct and different
viewpoint on the origin of our
observable universe as a series of
unending aeons or eons as sir roger
calls them where the universe starts in
a big bang
of one particular universe and then
expands becoming infinitely more tenuous
until it reaches this infinite state of
diffusion at which point in the far far
future perhaps trillions of years from
now the universe then recreates itself
via what's called conformal mapping
that sir roger has talked about on this
channel as well and that then is
identified with the new big bang of the
next cycle cyclic cosmologies are not
new here's a preprint uh from the year
negative 1000
which was when the archive just came
online and it shows the cyclic egyptian
cosmology
and i can't pronounce the author's name
but i'm sure he or she has a very high h
index
and this discovery or this prediction
rather that the universe is cyclical i
call everything new is old again in
other words this even predates perhaps
the biblical uni universe the singular
universe origin that we've talked about
after the biblical and egyptian
narratives there was the notion of an
aristotelian universe which was a
geocentric universe in which the fixed
spherical earth was at the center of the
universe and was surrounded by these
select celestial orbs or shells or
spheres onto which the planets and stars
were affects and they all orbited around
us on earth
very different cosmology then of course
galileo and copernicus ushered in the
the sun-centric or heliocentric universe
in the early 1600s and thanks to
galileo's observations
but it really wasn't proven that the
universe was not
oriented on the earth until 100 years or
so later in the 1700s when stellar
aberration was discovered but
nevertheless newton also had a version
of a static universe in which the
distant objects were held in place
effectively and that they were
maintained in in their fixed positions
uniformly distributed and the universe
was gravitationally uh unstable there
was not enough time for us to observe
the effects of the gravitational
instability if there was a small
perturbation to the dynamical
equilibrium that had predated newton and
everyone here to form now obviously we
don't believe that anymore
thanks to the work of albert einstein
who uh did come up with a modification
to newton's theory that didn't require
the stabilizing
phenomena or even the dynamical
disequilibrium of isaac newton instead
it was able to remain static via the
insertion of what he called the
cosmological term or the vacuum energy
later shown to be wrong and then later
brought back by adam reese past guests
on the show brian schmitz alpermuda
pearl mudder and their teams with the
discovery of a
of dark energy now the question of
whether the dark energy is constant or
not is a big question an open one that
we'll discuss in future videos
even after hubble lemaitre et cetera
came up with evidence for the expanding
universe the dynamical universe jeff
burbidge fred hoyle giant narlikar and
others came up with what was known as
this quasi-steady state universe a
universe that had a tiny production of
matter as required by the friedman
equations to cause the universe to
expand but it was only requiring a most
minuscule amount as hoyle would
poetically say about one atom per one
hydrogen atom per volume the size of the
empire state building per century now
that sounds like a tiny amount in a long
amount of time but think of how many
centuries fit in 13 billion years and
think of how many volumes the size of
the empire state building there are so
it was really kind of a trick of the eye
or trick of the year that uh hoyle and
burbidge would use nevertheless it was
an intriguing idea this creation field
the sea field that they posited
and of course i've talked about the big
bounce of anna aegis and paul steinhardt
and we will talk with anna aegis herself
in an upcoming video another candidate
for a single origin of a single universe
is of course the eternal inflationary
multiverse here are two comments by two
of its co-creators in a sense alan guth
and andre linde now a third creator is
of course
paul steinhardt who we've had on the
show and also have featured his
expanding universe via the bouncing
cosmological model
but all these models are very different
from inflation so all the models the
conformal cyclic cosmology and the
bouncing model the quasi-steady state
model et cetera et cetera they all
predict something very different from
inflation
[Applause]
the main distinction between the
bouncing models and the conformal cyclic
cosmology and the quasi-steady state
model is that they make a prediction
that there should be no background of
gravitational waves that would produce
the b mode polarization patterns that
myself and my colleagues on the simon's
observatory and bicep are working to
detect therefore
it is possible to falsify the
quasi-steady state the bouncing model
and the uh and the conformal cyclic
universe but not falsify the
inflationary multiverse because in a
multiverse a the universe could have
inflated but with too little inflation
or energy to produce a primordial tensor
mode background or b inflation might not
have even happened
and so it is possible in depending on
what universe we're in what the physical
properties are to have inflation occur
or not and not have b mode polarization
be the the true proof that inflation
took place and yet you could falsify by
discovering the primordial b mode
background you could falsify
quasi-steady state bouncing and
conformal cyclic cosmology those are
very different and there's a third point
which is not often pointed out by my
colleagues even sir roger himself and i
was honored to tell him this
on his 90th birthday
thank you very much for the talk and uh
lots of potential there and that is that
of all of these only the conformal
cyclic cosmology does not invoke a kind
of creation field a field that is known
as either the sea field and quasi
steady state cosmology or
this scalar field that is part of
inflationary cosmology and also in a
bouncing model as we've discussed there
is a scalar field which produces the
conditions that allow the universe to
bounce so conformal cyclic cosmology is
unique it is falsifiable and it doesn't
require a scalar field heretofore
unknown so that makes it very powerful
we can prove it wrong and we can also uh
go about our business not requiring
understanding of the universe as
possessing a scalar field so we've
talked a lot about the cmb on this
channel so we decided to build a
falsification experiment if you like it
could prove these three other theories
wrong and not prove inflation right but
motivate the existence of a primordial
tensor or gravitational wave background
[Music]
[Music]
this concludes the first part of our
special two-part birthday celebration
for sir roger penrose click here for my
interview that i did with sir roger
click here if you want to see an
interview with my other cosmology
friends stay tuned for part two or get
into some of the experimental
discoveries that my colleagues and i
hope to make